you are just such a New York guy I am
New York yeah but you're living in Los
Angeles now how are you liking it how do
you like LA I'll tell you something
about la la is awesome
you can do anything in this town except
making a left turn I mean that's it
if it's if it's digging on the left
don't even look at it you're never gonna
get there doesn't matter what it is
auditions jobs family I'm sorry you
should have been on the right side
all right you turned 50 earlier this
year is that right
how does it feel well you see that fear
in the crowd yeah well these are my
Lipitor years I'll tell you that right
now I am I thought being 50 would be
kind of like you know what who cares you
don't have to work out you can just sit
in a rocking chair listening to like a
police scanner and wait to die you know
but now it's extreme you got to like
kayaking have you ever Chi Act never
gone kayak okay let me tell you some
kayaking kayaking is the unicycle of the
sea it is so boring
am I right have you ever seen a guy look
like he's having a good time he's
kayaking no yeah he always has that look
like if I had one friend I would be
canoeing
[Laughter]
so no tie acting for you what about any
other sports or other things you go
water kayaking is what not swimming with
dolphins a dolphin right have you done
it never done that no I don't think I
can even afford it I mean honestly I
could not afford that's like a 1% or
like you know thing I would have to go
for the poor man dolphin rod you know
what that is right no no I don't bottle
a whiskey baby pool wet dog let's do it
on the cheap okay you know all right you
are you are single what's the dating
experience like right now well let me
ask you this you guys are both married
so you've never been on one of these new
dating sites
no okay I don't know if this ever
happened in the crowd where you are
you're on a dating site and by accident
you hit the wrong button and by accident
you enroll yourself at DeVry University
you have to go Conan I cannot not go get
it okay yeah once you're enrolled you
have to do after yeah 80 something now
you could probably fix her printer yeah
true thank you wasn't that a great clip
subscribe to my youtube channel
for an endless supply of me
[Laughter]